Okay....
Ups, ich wollte stehen machen.
Chat, heute was sagt ihr, weeps in oder weeps out?
Könnt ihr, könnt ihr euch überlegen, noch, noch ist Zeit.
Noch ist Zeit, weeps in oder weeps out?
Rockholz Fenster aufmachen.
Brocken.
Ah ja.
So.
Excellent.
Chat, Chat, wir müssen, wir müssen jetzt halben ASMR-Stream machen.
Ich darf nicht so laut reden, gerade.
Daku, Dankeschön für den Massive-Eyepad-Ultra-Mega-IQ-Sub.
Dan2Dev, 13 Monate Massive-Subscriptions hier.
Max, danke für den Sub.
Also der Kenpachi sucht ein 8-Port-Switch mit 2,5 Gigabit.
Was hältst du vom QNAP?
Aber die QNAP-Dinger finde ich ehrlich gesagt nie, fand ich noch nie sonderlich geil.
Ich hatte aber auch noch nie einen, aber die haben mich nie sonderlich angesprochen.
Ich mein, preislich geht's in Ordnung.
Ah, mein 5-Port-2,5 hat der MikroTik zu bieten.
Gut, guck mal.
Gut, tschüss.
Ach, das kann man ja wieder nicht gescheit suchen, gell?
Mehr RAM? Ja, ich hab genug RAM.
Tja, ich weiß, also keine Ahnung, was die da haben.
Gut, man kann natürlich einen 10G nehmen, also wenn du, jetzt mal ohne Scheiß, ne?
Aber ohne Scheiß, also du kannst einen 10-Gigabit-Switch nehmen.
Die können alle 2,5.
Die Frage ist halt nur, will man das extra Geld ausgeben, ne?
By the way, das ist überhaupt kein 8-Port-Switch, ne?
Was du da gezeigt hast, das ist ein...
Ach, Moment, den da, den da meinst du, ne?
Na, aber ganz ehrlich, ne, das ist ein 5-Port-Switch.
Ah, den gibt's in zwei Varianten.
Exzellent, exzellent. Ah, hier, guck mal.
Also ich muss sagen, preislich geht das, geht das aber tatsächlich.
Ich glaube, MikroTik hat in der Rechnung noch nix. Die haben jede Menge 10G.
Aber ansonsten nix Gescheites.
Ja, das sind die Router-Dinger, die bringen nix.
Wir gucken mal, ich bin ehrlich gesagt auch ein bisschen überfragt gerade, müssen wir mal schauen.
Ich erzähl gleich was, jaja. Ich erzähl gleich was.
Bis dahin ich vergessen hab. Cool.
Aber wir gucken mal, die haben doch hier so eine Suchgeschichte.
Leute, ich muss euch mal kurz blenden.
Boah, fliegen ja die Augen raus, ja.
So, 2,5.
Das ist Müll, das will man nicht haben.
Peeling.
Ein Crap nach dem anderen, man.
Ich hab letztens irgendwas gesehen.
Aber...
Ja, ich glaub, da kommen wir jetzt in Regionen, das muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Ich bin mir echt nicht sicher, ob die nicht was hacken.
Du willst ja AY-45-Stecker haben, ne?
Also du willst ja nicht S+, du willst AY-45-Stecker haben.
Ja, anscheinend haben die in der Richtung nix.
Was natürlich schlecht ist, weil 2,5G ist das neue 1G und wird es zumindest in ein paar Jahren sein.
Ich glaub, viele Leute haben das jetzt erst gecheckt, nachdem die ganzen Wi-Fi-Dinger theoretisch mehr können,
dass dann irgendwie 1G so langsam aber sicher mal vorbei ist.
Tja, ne, UniFi-Switche kaufe ich mir nicht.
Also muss ich sagen, die Mikrotik-Seite ist richtig beschissen zum Suchen, keine Ahnung.
Wundert mich.
Also die ganzen 10-Gigabit-Switches supporten alle 2,5, aber das lohnt sich ja nicht.
Was sagt dann Homelab?
Homelab ist doch immer gut.
Reddit, Homelab, 2,5G-Switch.
Dann stellen wir das Ganze jetzt mal um auf letztes Jahr.
Wir wollen ja was Gescheites haben.
Ich hab doch letztens irgendwo was gesehen.
Ich hab doch letztens irgendwo einen Switch gesehen.
Warte mal.
Irgendwo hab ich letztens, ich hab letztens eine Übersicht gesehen und da war auch ein Switch dabei.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, nicht so was Fettes.
Der Dick hier?
Ne.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr, aber ich bilde mir an, ich hab letztens irgendwas gesehen.
Na gut.
Oh, der Chat ist high IQ.
Der Chat hat was gepostet.
Ah, jetzt.
Wo hast denn das her?
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich auch irgendwo von Reddit, oder?
2,5.
Die D-Link.
Okay, D-Link ist meistens relativ...
Nope.
Sache mal, was ist das eigentlich für ein Schwachsinn?
Kann mir mal jemand erklären, warum kostet ein 2,5G-Switch mehr als ein 10G-Switch?
Weil die 10G-Switch können auch alle.
Ganz ehrlich, dann finde ich das, was du dir hier rausgesucht hast, gar nicht schlecht.
Das ist zwar komplett unmanaged, das ist aber auch egal, weil du willst ja eigentlich damit gar keine...
Du brauchst wahrscheinlich keinen WLAN-Support oder sonst was.
Da ist es nicht schlimm, dass der unmanaged ist.
Und ein unmanaged-Switch, der tut es eigentlich von nahe zu jedem Hersteller.
Ja dann, ne, du machst doch...
Guck mal, sogar fanless.
Ja, ne, macht doch eigentlich gar keinen schlechten Eindruck, kann man sich doch holen.
Stromverbrauch scheint auch okay zu sein.
Sind die noch ganz dicht?
Das braucht mehr als mein Desktop-Rechner im Idol.
Ach, das ist maximal Idol-Draw mit PoE.
Das ist, wenn man PoE anschaltet.
2,5 braucht kaum jemand.
Doch, ich bin der Meinung, 2,5 ist das neue 1G.
In den nächsten paar Jahren wird 2,5 komplett Standard sein.
Ich kenne einen Dienstleister, der bald Zeit hat, um Switches zu managen.
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass jemand einen Dienstleister hier aus dem Chat braucht, aber...
Falls ihr einen Dienstleister braucht, Chat, dann wendet euch an den Keeper XY, der weiß Bescheid.
Keine Ahnung, aber der macht auch einen ganz guten Eindruck hier, das Teilen, was ihr kaufen wolltest.
Wie war's, so gab es die Woche was Lustiges?
Ja, es gab wieder die üblichen...
Schafft das Kupfer 2,5G gut?
Ja, überhaupt kein Problem.
Naja, Kupfer ist mit 2,5G lacht sich kaputt.
Ich meine, du kannst auch 10G ohne Probleme über Kupfer machen.
Bei 100G bin ich mir allerdings, also bei 40 und 100G bin ich mir nicht sicher, inwieweit es da mit Kupfer aktuell ausschaut.
Keine Ahnung.
Ne, hab ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Jetzt sogar 40G, naja, dann im Zweifelsfall geht auch viel mehr, wenn die Kabel schon kurz sind.
Ja, also wie war meine Woche, gab es was Lustiges?
Lass mal überlegen, es gab die üblichen...
Eher Direct Attach geht, aber er will ja AJ45 Stöcke haben.
So, lass mal überlegen, gab es irgendwas Lustiges?
Es gab eigentlich nur die üblichen Schwachsinn von viel zu viel Gemiete.
Leute, die wieder keine Ahnung haben von dem, was sie erzählen.
Entwickler, die nicht checken, dass Ablaufdatum eines Zertifikats und Ablaufdatum von der Zertifizierungsstelle zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe sind.
Ansonsten eigentlich eher so das übliche, mir fällt grad nix ein.
Ja, Tabs, guck mal, ich hab hier Tabs und ich hab da auch nochmal Tabs.
Exzellent.
QNAP hab ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie ausprobiert.
Wie heißt noch mal diese Zertifizierungsstelle?
Die wurde hunderttausende für ausgeben kannst.
Das ist auch nicht QNAP, die heißt aber so ähnlich.
NetApp meine ich, die ultra teuer sind.
Wann kommt das Windows 11 Update? Ich hoffe, das dauert noch eine Weile.
McFly, danke für den Zapp. Selfmade Eyes, Arrow, massive. Guck mal, fast 30 Monate zusammen.
Schön, dass ihr am Start seid.
Versuche gerade, wenn ich was übersehe, schreibt es einfach nochmal in den Chat, ich bin grad ein bisschen lahm.
Ihr merkt es ja gerade, ich kann grad nicht so laut reden. Also nicht, das liegt nicht einmal am Hals, aber ich kann hier grad nicht so laut reden.
Aber ich hab gleich mal trotzdem Stream an.
Versuche gerade WakeOnLan über VPN zu machen. Problem ist das, sehen wir am PC für eine Weile aus, dass das nicht mehr funktioniert.
Sonst immer könnte das an einem anderen PC sein.
Nee, ich glaube eher, dass der PC nach einer Weile von irgendeinem normalen Standby in irgendein fast off Standby geht und dann die Netzwerkkarte nicht mehr mit Strom versorgt wird und das nicht mehr mitbekommt.
An irgendeinem Switch?
Unwahrscheinlich, wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss, ich bin mit dem PC schon immer mit Strom versorgt.
Ich bin mir jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht sicher, wie genau WakeOnLan Packages zugestellt werden. Ob das eine Layer 2 oder Layer 3 Geschichte ist.
Also ob man das auf irgendeine IP macht oder auf eine MAC-Adresse.
Ich hab das schon ewig her, dass ich mal irgendwas zu tun hatte mit WakeOnLan.
Vielleicht weiß das der Chat, der Chat ist 6headhierq, der weiß das.
Ich bin mir da wirklich, ich bin mir da echt nicht sicher. Was wird heute gemacht? Heute machen wir gar nichts Großartiges.
Heute kaufen wir noch ein paar Sachen ein. Ich muss endlich meinen Einkaufsdienst abhaken.
Das habe ich jetzt schon seit zwei Wochen hier.
Ich habe jetzt den Einkaufsdienst abhakt.
Ich habe jetzt einen dem Verkaufsdienst abhakt.
Ich habe einen dem Verkaufsdienst abhakt.
Heute kaufen wir noch ein paar Sachen ein, ich muss endlich meinen Einkaufstest abhaken,
das habe ich jetzt schon seit zwei Wochen hier aufgeschoben.
Wir gucken uns ein bisschen Zeug an und morgen gucken wir uns dann meine neuen Axis Points
an und probieren damit ein bisschen rum, weil ich habe mir jetzt ja auf Ebay, also übrigens
ein Schnapper diese Axis Points, wer mal viel Geld für Axis Points ausgeben will, kann
sich so ein hier holen, für nur 1367 Euro und davon habe ich auf Ebay welche gekauft,
also um genau zu sein, ich habe einen R600 und einen R701 gekauft, den R600 zum ausprobieren,
den R701 zum benutzen und ich habe 250 Euro bezahlt für den, was immer noch mehr ist
als Unify Axis Point, aber ist jetzt gebraucht, ist okay. Ich wollte auf den R650 bieten,
der ging dann aber hoch bis glaube 700 Euro oder so und das war es mir dann wirklich nicht
wert, dann nehme ich lieber Last Gen, das gucken wir uns morgen mal in Ruhe an, weil
das Ding ein paar Features hat, auf die ich wirklich gespannt bin. Wozu man das braucht?
Zum Beispiel, wenn du, okay hat ein paar Sachen, ich fange mal mit den Sachen an, die so nice
to have für mich sind, aber jetzt nicht so das Killer Feature, was ich haben will, also
das erste ist, die Dinger sind wohl wirklich richtig, das kann ich nicht beurteilen, das
ist bloß von dem, was ich gelesen habe, die Dinger haben wohl richtig gute Bildqualität,
also da ist nicht einfach nur quasi ein Kleiderbügel drin als Antenne, sondern auch die passende
Isolierung und alles, also die Dinger müssen von der Bildqualität richtig, richtig gut
sein. Das nächste ist, die haben ein proprietäres Beam Forming, also ein bisschen was in die
Richtung, wie das jetzt bei Wifi 6 ist, das ist quasi der Axis Point, mit, also das Gerät,
was die Pakete bekommen soll, quasi hauptsächlich in die Richtung abstrahlt, für das Gerät,
was es empfangen soll, was natürlich besser ist für Empfang und Senden und das eigentliche,
richtig, also ein weiteres Feature, was ich gut finde im Vergleich zu UniFi, die Dinger
gehen ohne Controller, weil, ich meine, der UniFi Controller ist ganz nice, wenn man,
ich meine, ich habe ja vier Axis Points mittlerweile, Erdgeschoss, erster Stock, Keller und dann
hier noch für die Terrasse und Garten draußen, dafür ist der UniFi Controller ganz nice,
aber ehrlich gesagt, ich finde die UniFi Geschichte an sich nicht so geil, also gerade der Controller,
wie die Sachen da benannt werden, da blickst du teilweise gar nicht durch, was gemeint
ist und UniFi selbst wohl auch nicht, dann machen die ganz komische automatische Magic
Sachen bei UniFi, die man am besten abschalten muss und generell, ich bin kein großer Fan
von dem UniFi Controller, auch das neue, ich finde es auch blöd, dass zum Beispiel, wenn
du bei dem UniFi Controller eine neue SSID aktivierst, also eine alte SSID, die du ausgeschaltet
hast, wieder aktivierst, dass der dann alle Axis Points rebooten muss und das ist ja noch
okay und das Problem ist, dass er 30-40 Sekunden rebooted und dann alle Geräte sich quer im
Haus neu verbinden und dann erstmal wieder den richtigen Axis Point finden müssen,
das ist eigentlich Müll, aber das hauptsächliche Feature, das hauptsächliche Zinglor, das
ist auch was für dich, warum ich mir den Kram gekauft habe, weil ich es gerade sehe
von dir, das hauptsächliche Feature oder vielleicht, es sei denn du möchtest WPA Enterprise
wirklich unbedingt machen dann, das hauptsächliche Feature, was ich bei den Dingern wirklich
gut finde ist, die haben die Möglichkeit, dass man, ich erkläre es jetzt mal wirklich,
dass man für jedes WLAN mehrere Passwörter vergeben kann, pro Gerät, also sprich, ich
kann jetzt beispielsweise für ein, ich habe das gleiche WLAN, WLAN Blob und ich kann jetzt
beispielsweise sagen, okay, wenn ich mit dem iPad das WLAN Blob joinen will, dann benutzt
das ein anderes Passwort, wie beispielsweise mein Raspberry Pi, also man kann sagen Default
Passwort, das gilt für alle Geräte, aber wenn man spezielle Geräte hat, beispielsweise
IOT Devices, zum Beispiel WLAN Steckdosen oder WLAN Lampen oder sowas, die man wegschmeißt
und man nicht möchte, dass jemand quasi aus dem Müll das WLAN Passwort rausholt, weil
das ja gespeichert ist auf den Geräten, dann vergibst du einfach für alle IOT Geräte
ein extra, also für jedes IOT Gerät ein extra WLAN Passwort und wenn du das Gerät wegschmeißt,
dann löscht du das und das bringt nichts, das dann aus dem Müll zu holen und das ist
halt ein richtig geiles Feature.
Warum macht man das nicht über WPA Enterprise, dafür ist es ja gedacht eigentlich, also
Radius, WPA, WLAN genügt mit Radius, weil die ganzen IOT Dinger kein WPA Enterprise
können.
Guckt euch mal die handelsübliche WLAN Steckdose an, da kann es schon froh sein, wenn das Ding
halbwegs neues WPA unterstützt.
Können kein WPA Enterprise und WPA Enterprise muss da klein können, dass es geht und diese
dynamische Pre-Shared-Key-Geschichte von den Dingern, die kann pro Gerät ein eigenes WLAN
Passwort vergeben.
Das ist halt richtig nice.
Kann man die auch in verschiedene WLANs schmeißen mit gleicher SSID?
Ja, du kannst WLAN Zuordnungen anhand des Passworts irgendwie machen, also du kannst
sagen, diese Geräte sollen in dieses WLAN kommen.
Das ist aber wohl mit der Controllerless-Firmware etwas trickreich, geht aber auch, habe ich
gelesen, bei denen im Forum, mit denen ihre Management Controller ist es easy.
Ja, das ist nice, ne?
Ja, und zu der Frage, irgendjemand hat gefragt, könnte man das nicht auch mit unterschiedlichen
SSIDs machen, doch das könnte man theoretisch schon mit unterschiedlichen SSIDs machen,
da ist es aber wieder der Unterschied zwischen Theorie und Praxis, weil, naja, du könntest
das theoretisch mit unterschiedlichen SSIDs machen, aber dann bräuchtest du ja quasi
eine SSID pro Gerät und das ist nicht praktikabel.
Also die meisten Access Points können maximal, also die Unified-Dinger können maximal 4 SSIDs
pro Gerät und das verschmutzt dir quasi auch komplett das WLAN, also das ist overhead ohne
Ende und du beeinflusst quasi die komplette Nachbarschaft, wenn du 50 SSIDs aufhast, das
will man eigentlich nicht haben und dich selbst vor allem.
Also das ist blöd, das zu machen.
So, Sophos oder PF-Sense?
Tja, ganz ehrlich, ich hatte mit Sophos noch nicht die Ehre, aber mit PF-Sense schon bzw.
mit Open Sense, wenn schon würde ich Open Sense nehmen, nicht PF-Sense, deswegen würde
ich zu PF-Sense tendieren bzw. zu Open Sense, weil ich das kenne, das andere kenne ich nicht.
Und für WLAN Sachen, wenn man jetzt wie gesagt nicht so gedünst machen möchte, sondern
eher dann so die Enterprise Sachen von Portal und sowas, da ist wohl PF-Sense bzw.
Open Sense richtig gut, weil ich weiß, dass bei uns auf der Arbeit, dass die Netzwerkleute,
die haben überall Cisco Access Points rumstehen und die können ja auch alles mögliche, aber
das eigentliche Handling für Login im Portal und solche Geschichten, das machen die mit
PF-Sense.
Also kann schon mal nicht so schlecht sein, ne?
Geizhals hat einen eigenen Dark Mode, echt?
Zeig mal her, wo ist der?
Ach hier, guck mal, oh, Pog, dann guck mal lieber bei ihm krasse Hacker-Kram, heute machen
wir nicht allzu viel hier, dafür gucken wir uns morgen neue Access Points an, oder was
heißt das, heute machen wir nichts, oder dann muss ich endlich meine Einkaufsliste abhaken
und ich hab nur noch eine Stunde Zeit, Keg-Wade, ja also wie gesagt bei Unified-Dinger bin
ich grad nicht so scharf drauf, ja für sowas ist Mikrotik richtig gut, weil preisleistungsmäßig
schlägt den Dinger nix, das wird gekauft, das was ich noch auf meiner Einkaufsliste
übrig hab, wahrscheinlich wird das heute wieder nix, das ist aber nicht schlecht, weil
dann hab ich immer noch was in der Hinterhand, was wir machen können und so lang es Chat-Sachen
gibt, kann ich mich ja damit erstmal auslassen, hier da findest du garantiert richtig gute
Mikrotik-Dinger, 2x10GR und 45, und je nachdem was du brauchst, kannst du dir auch vielleicht
einfach ein Modul einplanen, die ja auch nicht so teuer sind, na gut 40€ oder so, zu viel
Gemiete war diese Woche wieder und gewisse Leute, die mit G anfangen, du weißt wahrscheinlich
wen ich meine, haben wieder Verwirrung gestiftet, weil sie wieder Dinger erzählt haben, die
technisch nicht so ganz korrekt sind und hat damit andere Leute verwirrt.
Projektplaner 125 Tage geplant für eine Person, ein Business Stonks ja, ist es halt, ne will
ich nicht, hab ich schon ausprobiert, gefällt mir nicht, kennst du das hier, ja das kenn
ich, das hab ich bei mir daheim auch laufen, ich hab nen PXE-Server, aber der PXE-Server,
so jetzt kann ich ja nochmal drehen, der PXE-Server, der wird es nicht überleben, der fliegt bald
weg, ich benutze das Ding so gut wie nie, also warum soll ich weiter nen PXE-Server haben,
und guckt Leute, ich hab hier nen PXE-Server, also wenn ich hier ne VM einschalte, dann rebooten
wir, rebooten wir mal die Qt-VM, wobei die rebooten wir nicht, die rebooten wir, rebooten
Poggers, oh, Power off, zack, rebooten Poggers, hallo, und jetzt booten wir Netzwerk, ah ich
glaub ich hab kein EFI-Boot in meinem PXE drinne, ah hat sich eh schon erledigt, egal, dann
nicht, aber ich hab nen PXE-Server lokal offen, den benutze ich aber so gut wie nie,
deswegen wird er das nicht überleben, fliegt demnächst weg, gut das hab ich ja schon erklärt,
Windows NPS, ich hab keine Ahnung was NPS überhaupt ist, irgendein Microsoft Ding,
und dann bin ich ganz froh sogar, dass ich das nicht kenne, umso weniger Microsoft Sachen
ich kenne, umso besser, Network Policy Server, Radius von, ah ok, natürlich, Microsoft kann
den Kram natürlich nicht so nennen, das ist ja logisch, hast du schon das neue 05-Video
geschaut, nein, aber ich habe, ich hab mir gestern das Foto von unserem schwarzen Loch
aus dem Zentrum der Milchstraße angeguckt, habt ihr das auch schon gesehen, das ist richtig
POG-G, ich mein, es sieht so aus, als hat man ne Linse wo was draufpappt, aber das täuscht
er eh, weil das ist ja kein sichtbares Licht, das sind irgendwelche Radioteleskope glaub
ich, die das machen, das sind irgendwelche Radioteleskope, das heißt das ist im Endeffekt
eh nur, oder was heißt nur, das ist quasi das was man empfangen hat, so umgewandelt
wird, dass man halt was sieht, aber im Prinzip, gut, ich mein normale Bilder funktionieren
gerade, normale digitale Bilder oder auch analoge Bilder funktionieren ja auch, da fällt, da
sind in dem Fall sind es halt Photonen, die auf irgendeinem Trägermaterial fallen und
dann das Bild ergeben und da hat man halt die Sachen empfangen anderweitig und hat
da jetzt ein Bild draus berechnet, ist trotzdem eine richtig geile Geschichte, wenn man sich
überlegt, dass das, ich mein das ist jetzt deutlich näher als das letzte Bild, ich
glaub im Prinzip sind es immer Photonen, im Prinzip immer elektromagnetischer Kram,
wie gesagt ich bin weder Physiker noch Mathematiker noch sonst was, ich hab keine Ahnung von was
ich eigentlich rede ja, so, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, das ist viel näher als das,
das letzte schwarze Loch Bild kennt wahrscheinlich noch fast jeder, das war deutlich deutlich
weiter weg, aber halt auch viel viel schwerer, also ich krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht hin,
also das letzte schwarze Loch war keine Ahnung, Millionen Lichtjahre weg, irgendwie 30 Millionen
Lichtjahre oder so, also weit, ich hab keine Ahnung ob das jetzt stimmt und das hier ist
glaube ich nur knapp 25.000 Lichtjahre weg, dafür ist das deutlich kleiner beziehungsweise
Masse ärmer als das was sie zuerst fotografiert haben, das heißt die sind ungefähr so gleich
groß, also auf die Entfernung betrachtet, was halt echt krass ist, wenn man sich überlegt,
ich mein das ist zwar ein ultraschweres Ding, wenn man das mal so an den Sachen was bei
uns im Sonnensystem unterwegs ist fest macht, aber das ist halt auch weit weg, ich mein
auch 25.000 Lichtjahre oder so, ich weiß nicht ob das hier drinne steht wie weit das weg
ist, ich glaub irgendwie 25.000 Lichtjahre oder irgendwie sowas war das weg, na gut was
auch immer die Tagesschauder schreibt, ich hab das nur wegen dem Foto aufgemacht und
das ist halt echt krass, wenn man sich überlegt, das ist so klein, dass du, boah was hab ich
letztens für einen Vergleich gehört, wenn einer in New York sitzt und dort sein Kaffee
bezahlt, siehst du quasi das Kleingeld von ihm, wenn du das von hier aufnehmen würdest,
also so klein ist das und das hat ja auch nur funktioniert, weil man mehrere Teleskope
auf der Erde zusammengeschaltet hat, also mehrere Radioteleskope auf der Erde zusammengeschaltet
hat und deswegen hat man gerade so die Auflösung hinbekommen, die man braucht, dass man das
überhaupt erkennen kann, es war der Bierschirm, nein ich hab nix von Harald Lösch geschaut,
ich hab vor ein paar Tagen Urknall Weltall und das Leben geschaut, wo aber noch nicht
dieses Foto raus war, wo es darum ging ob der nicht vielleicht sowas kommen könnte, da
ging es auch darum, aber wie gesagt ich folge solchen Sachen schon lange, ich finde das
super interessant das Thema, natürlich bin ich hier auch bloß Hobbyzuschauer, ne Farbenatlas
das war das alte, ja zumindest, mal gucken ob die irgendeiner was die Lichter die Entfernung
schreibt, Licht, hallo, wie heißt unser schwarzes Loch, Sagitarius A, A Stern, A Stern, bitteschön
ja, ist entfernt 25.000 Lichtjahre, Leute für aus dem Kopf ist doch gar nicht so schlecht
oder, du hast recht, pass auf was du googelst, wer weiß, ja schwarzes Loch sollte ich vielleicht
nicht googeln, da ist schon was dran, ja, ich glaube nicht, dass das die einzigen sind
von denen wir Bilder machen können, man hat ja vieles noch gar nicht, vielleicht von denen
die man bis jetzt kennt, es muss halt hinkommen von Masse und Entfernung, sodass man das auflösen
kann, da gibt es bestimmt noch mehr, aber wir haben ja noch lange nicht, wenn man sich
mal anguckt, so quasi was vom Universum um uns überhaupt gemapt ist im Endeffekt, wo
man schon mal hingeguckt hat, das ist ja gar nicht so viel, vieles sehen wir halt auch nicht,
weil du dadurch irgendwelche Nebel und sonst was gucken müsstest, aber da kann ich mir
durchaus vorstellen, dass es so groß ist, dass es da noch was gibt, aber vielleicht
von den Bekannten bisher, ja, und was ich halt richtig nice finde ist, und das kann
ich jetzt insofern halt auch nur wiedergeben, was man liest, beziehungsweise, wie gesagt,
ich hab den Kram ja nicht studiert, was ich halt mega nice finde ist, dass das im Endeffekt
genauso ausschaut, also beim ersten auch schon, dass das, ähm, quasi genauso ausschaut,
wie man das erwartet hat, also im Endeffekt, also, wie gesagt, ich hab da nicht wirklich
viel Plan von, im Endeffekt ist das hier, also hier in der Mitte sieht man ja quasi
nur den Schatten, das hier in der Mitte ist quasi das, was man nicht sieht vom schwarzen
Loch, ja, und das hier außen drum herum ist halt heißes, ja, Plasma im Endeffekt, also
sprich, das ist Materie, was das schwarze Loch irgendwie angesaugt hat, und das kreist
da jetzt ganz schnell drum herum, sodass sich das halt erhitzt und wahnsinnig heiß wird,
also sprich, das fällt wahrscheinlich irgendwann auch mal da rein, aber aktuell flitzt es
ganz schnell da rum und, ähm, wird saumäßig heiß, deswegen leuchten die Dinger ja auch
so hell, deswegen sieht man solche Sachen auch so gut, ja, äh, also das ist schon,
das ist richtig krass, weil man sich überlegt, dass man noch vor, keine Ahnung, 100 Jahren
oder so gedacht hat, ähm, dass es quasi, das Universum nur aus der Milchstraße besteht,
das ist schon heftig, oder, also da hat sich schon viel getan, das ist halt extrem hell,
das ist ja auch das, was es so quasi mit Quasaren und so gibt, das sind dann halt super weit,
entfernte, aber sehr massereiche schwarze Löcher mit ganz viel, tja, äh, Kram drum
herum, was leuchtet, ich kann es euch nicht erklären, weil ich genauso wenig Plan habe
wie ihr davon, sondern einfach nur Videos gucke, wo man früher gedacht hat, das sind
halt irgendwelche Sterne, bis man dann dahinter gekommen ist, nee, nee, das sind keine Sterne,
nein, das ist nicht im sichtbaren Bereich, nein, das ist nicht im sichtbaren Bereich,
das hat man quasi, dass die Daten, die man empfangen hat, hat man quasi umgerechnet
in wahrscheinlich so Wärme oder so, keine Ahnung, naja, es waren mal Sterne, kann man
sagen, ich mein, aber mittlerweile sind gerade die besonders weit entfernten schwarze Löcher,
die halt hell leuchten, das ist halt, was weiß ich, wie viele Milliarden Sonnenmassen
da drin sind, ja, es waren mal Sterne, ja, es waren alle Sterne, Leute, wir waren auch
mal Sterne, könnt ihr euch das vorstellen, also alles was von euch nicht gerade Wasserstoff
oder Helium ist, waren mal Sterne, kann man sich nicht vorstellen, aber ist so, aber eigentlich
nur Wasserstoff, nee, nee, ich glaube Wasserstoff und Helium, also wir sind aus Sternenstaub,
wenn man so will, weil das Universum besteht quasi zu, fragt mich nicht, ganz, ganz viel
groß im Anteil aus Wasserstoff und Helium, irgendwo, wo halt mal ein bisschen mehr Wasserstoff
ist, also irgendwelche Gaswolken im Universum, wo halt mal ein bisschen mehr ist an einer
Stelle, fangen dann halt irgendwann an durch die Gravitation, die Dinger, das Gas zusammenzuziehen
und wenn es dicht genug ist, gibt es dann irgendwann mal ein Stern und der leuchtet
dann je nachdem wie groß er ist, ein paar Millionen bis Milliarden Jahre und irgendwann
geht ihm halt sein Material aus, ja und dann wird alles mögliche an anderen Elementen
produziert, aus dem wir letztendlich auch bestehen, also wir waren auch mal, nicht so
krass, aber wir waren auch mal quasi ein Stern, ja, Leute mir geht übrigens auch die Materie
langsam aus, wo wir beim Thema sind, guckt mal es ist geschafft, letztens erst noch angekündigt,
ist geschafft, 99,4 POG, also meine Materie geht auch langsam aus, also ich habe es jetzt
geschafft, ich habe angefangen vor zwei Monaten oder so, ich habe es euch ja damals erzählt,
aber irgendwie 108,5, also es sind jetzt sag mal mal bald 10 Kilo, ich brauche noch 900
Gramm, müssen noch weg, ja, wir haben übrigens, wo wir gerade noch, wo wir gerade noch, wir
haben übrigens Glück, dass, wir haben übrigens Glück, dass unsere Sonne nicht so groß ist,
weil wenn unsere Sonne deutlich größer wäre, also mal abgesehen davon, dass es uns in dieser
Konstellation wahrscheinlich gar nicht gegeben hätte, aber wenn unsere Sonne deutlich größer
gewesen wäre, dann würde es sie wahrscheinlich schon gar nicht mehr geben und dann hätte
es uns als recht nicht gegeben, weil in der Regel ist es glaube ich so, umso größer
Sterne sind, umso kurzlebiger sind sie in der Regel auch, ja aber auch, dass sie das
geschafft haben aufzunehmen, wenn man sich mal überlegt, was da eigentlich alles dahinter
steckt, die haben ja irgendwie einige Teleskope über die ganze Welt verteilt, die Sache ist
halt die, du kannst nicht einfach die Teleskope nehmen und dann einfach mal da so grob in
die Richtung gucken und dann das danach irgendwie zusammenrechnen, du musst die Dinger synchronisieren
und das ist wohl kein einfaches Unterfangen, das quasi im, im, ja ich glaube mal Millisekunden
reicht, also ich sag jetzt einfach mal im Millisekundenbereich, das zu synchronisieren
weltweit, das ist nicht ohne, deswegen finde ich es auch wirklich beeindruckend, was sie
auf die Reihe gekriegt haben, generell, es gab die letzten Jahre so viel angefangen
von, wo sie Gravitationswellen entdeckt haben, jetzt zu Bildern von irgendwelchen Schwarze,
ich meine es ist ja kein direktes Bild, weil das eigentlich Schwarze noch sieht man ja
nicht, man sieht bloß, dass man nichts sieht und dass es Sachen gibt, was anscheinend sehr
heißes gibt, was da drum herum kreist, aber da hat es schon wirklich viel getan und wisst
ihr was ich, wie sage ich das jetzt am besten, also ich finde es etwas blöd, dass so viele
Leute das nicht anerkennen, ja, also gerade wenn ich da, bei Heise kommen ja auch öfters
mal so Meldungen oder so, dann gucke ich in das Heiseforum, da sind so viele Leute so
nach dem Motto, ja kann man das essen, also nein, also ist das unsinnig oder ja welche
Probleme löst das, ja das löst nicht den Klimawandel, das löst sonst nichts, ich finde
schon, dass das was, ich meine ob es was löst, das wissen wir ja teilweise bei neuen Sachen
eh erst 1-200 Jahre später, ja es gibt ja genug Sachen, die wurden erfunden und war
unmittelbar erstmal, tja, nice to have, aber da, ich meine allein schon, Leute, allein
schon dass wir jetzt hier sitzen, ich hier laber, wir uns das Bild angucken, da mussten
auch viele Sachen für erfunden werden, dass das notwendig ist und man hat bei der Erfindung
dieser Sachen ursprünglich auch nicht gedacht, ach ja wir sitzen dann 2022 mal da und machen
Livestream auf Twitch, ja das finde ich immer blöd, dass viele Leute das immer so herablassend
sehen, so gar nicht was da für ein quasi ein riesen Knowhow dahinter steckt, für
ein riesen Aufwand, für ein riesen Ehrgeiz und Herzblut und Energie bei den Leuten auch
reinfließt, die diese Forschung in dieser Richtung oder generell Forschung aber auch
in diese Richtung betreiben, dass gerade Leute, die, keine Ahnung, noch nicht mal, was gibt
es jetzt da für ein gutes Beispiel, die noch nicht mal in der Lage sind ihre Mikrowelle
alleine anzuschließen, dann in irgendeinem Forum gehen und darüber rum meckern, so nach
dem Motto, ja, ja, die Wissenschaftler mal wieder, haben sie mal wieder irgendwas entdeckt,
haha, ihr kennt solche Leute, das triggert mich immer ungemein, weißt du, Leute, die
geistig, wie gesagt, zu blöd sind ihre Mikrowelle selbst anzuschließen, wenn man sich ihre Posting-Historie
mal anguckt, sind, tun dann so, als könnten sie das in irgendeiner Art und Weise quasi
schlecht reden, weil das ja total unbedeutend ist, das, das geht mir, das geht mir immer
echt richtig, richtig, gegen, gegen den Strich, ich mein, bei vielen Sachen, wenn sie entdeckt
werden, wenn sie erfunden werden, weißt du noch nicht, wofür sie gut sind und im Zuge
dessen, was dort alles erfunden wurde, gemacht wurde, kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass
da der Allgemeinheit was zugute kommt, aber nichtsdestotrotz unabhängig davon, unabhängig
davon, ob, ähm, vielleicht irgendwelche Erfindungen da mal wirklich, man guckt euch GPS an und
solche Geschichten, das kam auch nicht einfach mal so, dass morgen eine aufgewacht ist, hat
man sich gedacht, ach, wir bauen jetzt GPS und dann hat es funktioniert, naja, unabhängig
davon, muss ich sagen, allein schon die, die Symbolkraft, könnte man vielleicht sagen,
keine Ahnung, dass man zusammen, das ist ja nicht einer, der da mit seinem Fernrohr sitzt
und hochguckt und sagt, aha, guck mal da, das schwarze Loch, da machen wir jetzt mal
ein Foto von, es ist ja noch nicht mal ein Foto, ähm, sondern dass das, dass das hunderte
Leute sind, die da weltweit teilweise an wissenschaftlichen Sachen zusammenarbeiten, da kommen dann
richtig so großartige Erkenntnisse raus, ähm, dass man auch sieht, dass wir uns nicht nur
gegenseitig umbringen können, sondern auch, und das ist eigentlich das viel bessere, sondern
auch zusammen komplett neue Ufer erschließen können, ihr wisst, wie ich es meine, nicht
so, ja, das finde ich bei solchen Sachen immer cool, was sehen wir hier, wir sehen
ein Foto von dem schwarzen Loch, wahrscheinlich von dem vermutlich schwarzen Loch im Zentrum
unserer Milchstraße, ja, gut, so, haben wir uns jetzt angeguckt, euch ein bisschen rum
philosophiert, ja, aber das finde ich, das finde ich wirklich cool, ja, das ist übrigens
das, wofür ich auch, wofür ich auch gerne Steuern bezahle, dass solche Forschung betrieben
werden kann, Akkretionsscheibe, ich kann das Wort nicht aussprechen, ja, genau, das sehen
wir, also ich meine, das schwarze Loch selbst, das sieht man nicht wirklich, weil wie auch,
aber man kann es halt erahnen dadurch, und es hat sich die letzten, guck mal, wenn man
sich überlegt, es hat sich die letzten hundert Jahre so unglaublich viel getan, irgendwie
1900 rum oder so, hatte man relativ wenig Plan noch, vergleich zu heute, so nach dem Motto,
ja, mehr als die Milchstraße gibt es nicht, von dass sich das Universum ausdehnt, wusste
damals auch keiner, was, da hat sich sehr viel getan, gerade auch die letzten hundert Jahre,
vor allem halt auch, weil wir jetzt Computer und solche Geschichten haben, und dass es
immer noch Leute gibt, die das quasi so herabschauend immer abtun, so nach dem Motto, ja, ja, was
denn die Wissenschaftler wieder erzählen, ja, die Leute, die könnten ohne das, was die
Wissenschaftler die letzten hundert Jahre rausbekommen haben, heute wahrscheinlich, noch nicht
mal ihren Fernseher, ihren Internet, ihren Radio, ihren Computer, ihr Smartphone, Internet,
was auch immer, das würde gar nicht existieren, ohne viele Erfindungen der letzten hundert
Jahre, und hätten die dann auch damals gesagt, so nach dem Motto, ja, ja, da hat mal wieder
einer was erfunden, was ein Schwachsinn, wer will denn sowas, wisst ihr, keine Ahnung,
die Leute triggern mich da teilweise immer richtig krass, das ist der Wahnsinn, es gibt
ja noch Leute, die denken, dass die Mondlandung fake war, ja, hey, es gibt auch Leute, die
denken, dass die Erde flach ist, und erzählen sonstige Dinger von magnetischen Ablenkungen
bis hast du nicht gesehen, und alles, was man an quasi Footage, also Video Bilder hat,
zum Beispiel von, wie sich die Sonne am Südpol bewegt und sowas, da sagen sie, alles fake,
das ist fake, das ist fake, das ist halt der Wahnsinn, es wird einfach zu allem, was man
nicht erklären kann, bzw. was der Sache widerspricht, wird einfach gesagt, fake, das ist fake, das
ist fake, mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich lasse das Bild nochmal kurz eingeblendet, während
ich das sage, ich finde, ganz ehrlich, diese Sache mit flacher Erde, ich finde das auch
immer lustig zu memeen, alles, ja, da kannst du super Witze drüber machen, und kannst
du auch, kannst du gerade super Ami-Kokona-Witze drüber machen, aber ganz im Ernst, wer wirklich
denkt, dass die Erde flach ist, bzw. eine Scheibe und flach, man könnte ja auch quadratisch
sein und flach und keine Ahnung, also, wer das wirklich denkt im Jahr 2022 noch, also,
das ist ja wirklich quasi schon eine Beleidigung aller, ja, wie soll man sagen, aller Forscher
und Wissenschaftler der letzten 2000 Jahre, die sich um sowas Gedanken gemacht haben,
also, ich mein, und selbst, wenn man jetzt sagen würde, wir wissen, selbst wenn man
jetzt mal einen Schritt zurück gehen würde und sagen, hey, ok, es ist nicht 100%ig, dass
die Erde eine Kugel, ich sage noch nicht mal genau eine Kugel, es ist nicht 100%ig, dass
die Erde eine Kugel ist, ok, 100%ig ist nichts, Leute, wenn ich jetzt außen, ich frage euch
mal, stellt euch mal vor, ich gehe jetzt nach Frankfurt auf den Messeturm, ich zeige
euch mal Frankfurt Messeturm, so, das ist relativ hoch, also der Messeturm in Frankfurt
ist 200-256 Meter, so, und ich würde euch jetzt fragen, Chet, wenn ich von da oben runter
springe, überlebe ich es oder, bin ich danach tot, 0 oder 100%, dann würde man sagen, naja,
sehr, sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich 99,99999999% tot, aber nicht 100%ig, also 100%ig, also
mal so 0% oder 100%, das sind die wenigsten Sachen, ja, und das lasse ich mir ja noch
gefallen, wenn einer sagt, es ist nicht 100%ig, dass die Erde rund ist bzw. dass die Erde
eine Kugel ist, ok, meinetwegen, aber selbst wenn man das mal alles weglässt, es ist vollkommen
egal, ob man jetzt sagt, ja, das ist die Wahrheit, ja oder nein, was doch eigentlich viel wichtiger
ist, mit diesem Modell, was wir so haben, auch seit Newton mit Gravitation und was wir,
und selbst wenn man sagt, hey, alles fake, was wir aus dem Weltall aufgenommen haben,
alles fake mit der Mondlande, selbst wenn man das sagen würde, die eigentliche Frage ist
doch viel eher, mit welchem Modell oder sagen wir mal, mit welcher Theorie kommt man weiter,
mit dem nicht wirklich vorhandenen Modell, dass die Erde flach ist und das keiner so
genau irgendwie erklären kann, noch nicht mal genau Jahreszeit, noch nicht mal genau
Ebbe und Flut, noch nicht mal irgendwie Mond, Sonnenposition, was auch immer oder mit dem
anderen Modell, selbst wenn man sagt, wir wissen es nicht 100%ig, ich mein, wir dürfen
nicht vergessen, so mit diesem, nennen wir es mal Standard, der sich so etabliert hat,
die letzten paar hundert Jahre, ja, also angefangen von Newton mit Gravitation, das ist der mit
dem Baum und dem Apfel und allen Sachen, die wir rausbekommen, rausgefunden haben, sodass
jetzt auch sowas wie GPS funktioniert und wo wir es geschafft haben mit, also mit wir
meine ich die Menschheit jetzt, wo wir es geschafft haben auf einem Asteroid zu landen
und da Fotos zu machen, was, welches Modell funktioniert besser, das ist doch das, was
man sich eigentlich fragen muss, selbst wenn man sagt, nein, nein, das ist nicht die 100%ige
Wahrheit, aber welches Modell kann mehr erklären, bessere Voraussagen machen und mit welchem
Modell haben wir quasi schon Dinge gemacht, die mit dem anderen gar nicht möglich gewesen
wären, also was funktioniert einfach unterm Strich besser, was kann Planetenposition erklären,
was kann Sonnen- und Mondfinsternis, Voraussagen vor allem, Schatten, die auf die Erde geworfen
werden, was kannst du eigentlich noch mehr wollen, natürlich kann man jetzt sagen, es
ist alles alles fake, was es gibt, das bringt einem aber nichts, weil man kann es trotzdem
nicht mit seinem Modell erklären und selbst wenn es überhaupt nicht stimmt, vielleicht
ist ja die Erde gar nicht wirklich rund oder vielleicht ist ja auch die Erde gar keine
Kugel, sondern ist irgendwie ein, was weiß ich, fünfdimensionaler Fivehead Raum oder
so und sieht für uns so kugelförmig aus, was auch immer, keine Ahnung, ist dieses Modell
für unsere aktuellen, für unsere aktuellen Kenntnisse und was wir damit gemacht haben
eigentlich gar nicht mal so schlecht, also wir kommen damit ja relativ gut hin, wir können
damit zum Beispiel auch erklären, dass wenn ich jetzt vor Messeturm springe, warum ich
dann, jetzt kommt's, warum ich dann quasi, ich nenne es mal, nach unten falle und nicht
nach oben, was übrigens ein Flacherdler auch nicht richtig erklären kann, weil die ja sagen,
gibt da nichts einheitliches, die sagen ja zum Beispiel, Gravitation gibt es nicht, das
ist eigentlich auch ziemlich Fivehead von denen, weil dadurch, dass sie quasi die grundlegende
Sache in Frage stellen, ist es überhaupt nur möglich, dass das keine Kugel ist, die sagen,
gibt das nicht, die sagen, es liegt an der Dichte, das Problem, was ich bloß sehe, ist,
wenn das nur an der Dichte liegt, warum falle ich dann nach unten und nicht nach oben, naja,
also es ist so viel Blödsinn dabei, also, ne, das kann ich nicht verstehen, dass das
wirklich heute noch, Leute ernsthafte Zweifel dran haben und dann alles als Fake, ja, verunglimpfen,
was dafür spricht, bzw. was ganz klar das belegt, ich mein, das ist genauso wie die,
die erzählen so nach dem Motto, jaja, auf der Rückseite des Mondes ist irgendwas, ne,
das Problem ist, es gab schon Sonden, die haben die Rückseite des Mondes fotografiert,
da ist nichts, ok, Steine und Staub und im Prinzip sieht die Rückseite des Mondes aus
wie die Vorderseite des Mondes, bloß man sieht sie halt nicht, ja, also von uns aus sieht
man sie nicht, ansonsten ist da gar nichts besonderes dabei, tja, ich hab letztens in
irgendeinem Flat Earth Video gesehen, der hat die ganze Zeit gesagt Dark Side of the Moon,
was er damit meinte ist, die Seite, die man nicht sieht, aber er hat die ganze Zeit so
getan, als wäre da immer Nacht, das ist ja Schwachsinn, die Sonne scheint auch auf die
andere Seite des Mondes, wir sehen es bloß nicht und warum sehen wir es nicht, naja,
weil der Mond immer in die gleiche Richtung, also weil das, wie heißt denn das, auf Deutsch
gezeiten, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das auf Deutsch heißt, also sprich, dass der Mond
immer in die gleiche Richtung guckt, zu uns, also der Mond dreht sich nicht um die Erde
in dem Sinn, dass er sich quasi um die eigene Achse nochmal dreht, sondern er guckt immer
in die gleiche Richtung der Erde, Tidal Locked heißt das auf Englisch, weiß nicht, wie
das auf Deutsch heißt, gezeiten, keine Ahnung, was, Deutsch, gezeiten, gesperrt, ne, ach
keine Ahnung, ja deswegen sehen wir die Rückseite nicht, das heißt ja nicht, dass da nicht die
Sonne drauf scheint, naja, gut, aber Kokona, Kokona Video, ja, hat wer Erfahrungen gemacht
mit der Virtual Box, ne, Virtual Box und Mac OS habe ich noch nie zusammen in Kombinationen,
ja, der macht ganz gute Videos, ich, hat jemand von euch das erste Video gesehen, wo er diese
Geschichte versucht hat zu erklären mit, eine Kabel, ein Kabel bis zum Mond und dann
die Klübirne einschalten, da ist ja englischsprachiges, das englischsprachige Technik YouTube eskaliert,
da hat jeder ein Reaction Video zugemacht, was im Endeffekt wahrscheinlich 100.000 neue
Subs gebracht hat, wo jeder, wo jeder, Electro Boom hat was zu erzählt, alle, alle haben
so was zu erzählen, und jetzt hat er letztens ein neues Video gemacht, wo das aber etwas
ausführlicher erklärt.
Ich bin zu USB, genau, was für PPL, äh, also diese Sache mit, dass du pro WLAN, ja,
eigene Passwörter vergeben kannst, das gibt es von mehreren Herstellern, also PPSK heißt
es bei Ruggus, bei TP-Link heißt es glaube ich auch so, ne, DPSK heißt es glaube ich
bei Ruggus, keine Ahnung, du hast MPSK, DPSK, IPSK, das haben eigentlich alle mehr oder
weniger größeren, außer Unify, die haben es nicht, äh, größeren Hersteller, das Problem
ist nur, dass es meistens nicht attraktiv ist, sich diese Dinger zu kaufen, ja, bei
den einen brauchst du irgendwelche Cloud-Management-Software, bei den anderen brauchst du irgendeine super
teure Enterprise-Controller-Lizenz und sonst was, also erschwinglich ist es sich auf Ebay
einen, einen Ruggus, Ruggus, Ruggus-Access-Point zu kaufen, äh, gebrauchten, es ist erschwinglich
sich, äh, so ein TP-Link-Omada-Ding zu kaufen, Mikrotik kann es auch, aber hat nicht so
schön, ist auch erschwinglich, ähm, eventuell OpenWRT demnächst, der Merchrequest ist ja
schon auf, auf GitHub und sollte hoffentlich demnächst aufgemercht werden, ja, die anderen
haben meistens irgendwelche Nachteile, Unify will es irgendwie nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung
warum Unify das nicht will, das wäre eigentlich wirklich sinnvolles Feature für die.
Ja, das stimmt, da hab ich auch ein paar Videos drüber gesehen, das, das liegt aber daran,
weil bei Interstellar waren wohl relativ viele Fivehead-Physiker bei der Beratung dabei,
also das ist nicht einfach nur zufälligerweise so, gut, ich mein, einiges davon ist halt
auch komplett, äh, naja, also, dass es in einem schwarzen Loch quasi, wie im Wandschrank,
äh, wie im Kleiderschrank von der 15-Jährigen ist oder wie ist es genau, nee, im Bücherregal,
nicht im Kleiderschrank, im Bücherregal, äh, ist, nun ja, das ist jetzt halt so in dem
Film, ja, was ist denn jetzt schon wieder Monkathos, achso, im Kleiderschrank von der
15-Jährigen, ok, alles klar, Chet, wenn das schon eure Meinung nach Monkathos ist, meinetwegen,
habt ihr da Erfahrung mit oder wie ist das, Chet, so langsam mach ich mir Gedanken, ja,
genau, es gibt sehr viele Faktoren ohne die es uns nicht gebe, also allein schon der Abstand,
äh, Erdesonne, dann, dass die Erde ein Magnetfeld hat, dann, dass wir ein Mond haben, ähm, generell
der Aufbau vom Sonnensystem, also es gibt, es gibt so viele Sachen, die sein können,
dass es uns nicht gebe, ja, das stimmt, aber erstmal, erstmal muss es Kohlenstoff geben,
ursprünglich gibt es Wasserstoff und Helium, beziehungsweise, ich bin gar nicht sicher,
aber ich glaube, also Wasserstoff definitiv und Helium, gut, Sterne ist Fusion Wasserstoff
zu Helium, also im Prinzip gab es, sagen wir mal, Wasserstoff und Helium, dass es Kohlenstoff
überhaupt gibt, äh, mussten erst ein paar Sterne explodieren.
Ja, das, das ist echt so, das sind im Prinzip, guck mal, das ist also Wifi-Antenne in Größe
der Erde, ja, so könnte man das auch sehen.
Femtosekunden brauchst du zur Synchronisierung, ja, ja, das ist absoluter, also krasser Scheiß,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Nullen, äh, nach dem Komma eine Femtosekunde hat, was
ist das, Femtosekunde, Femtosekunde, was ist das, das ist, achja, alles klar, ok, weirdchamp,
also quasi eine Million, eine, Billardsel oder sowas, keine Ahnung, weiß ich gar nicht,
wie man das nennt, ja, da gab es ja auch schon die ersten Bilder von, da gab es ja
auch schon, das waren ja glaube ich Kalibrierungsbilder, da gab es ja auch schon die ersten Bilder
dazu, was auch richtiges Five-Hat-Projekt ist, tja, da kann man sich jetzt drüber
streiten, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, man könnte auch sagen, jeder Punkt ist der
Mittelpunkt, oder auch nicht, dass ich, dass ich, jeder und kein Punkt ist der Mittelpunkt,
weil wenn du nach links guckst, wenn du nach rechts guckst, egal in welche Richtung du
guckst, es bewegt sich alles voneinander weg, und so könnte man ja schon sagen, ja gut,
wenn sich alles von uns weg bewegt, dann müssten wir ja in der Mitte sein, das Problem ist,
dass das von jedem Punkt aus so ist, ja also, da habe ich mich ja gerade schon drüber ausgelassen,
ich wusste gar nicht, dass Mondlandungszweifel heute noch angesagt sind, ich, also meine
Lieblings, persönliche Lieblingsverschwörungstheorie ist Obamas Exenmensch Bodyguard, den finde
ich immer noch am besten, und was ich auch gut finde ist, die Leute, die sagen, dass
die internationale Raumstation unter Wasser ist, und das würde man angeblich daran erkennen,
weil im Hintergrund ab und zu Blasen zu erkennen sind, unter Wasser, ja ja, angeblich, also
je nachdem, wen du fragst, ich glaube viele sind sich da in dem Punkt auch nur einig,
dass es fake ist, aber die haben unterschiedliche Erklärungen für, und wenn die Erklärungen
so bescheuert sind, also wenn die Erklärungen abgedrehter sind, und es mehr komischen Shit
braucht, um das zu erklären, als, dass die einfach im Weltall sind, dann würde ich sagen,
in dem Fall, glaube ich denen einfach mal, dass sie im Weltall sind.
Es gibt keine, nee nee, Moment, Moment, das ist je nachdem, welchen Flat Earthner du fragst,
ist der Südpol quasi einmal um die Scheibe eine Eiswand, wie auch immer das genau gehen
soll, das kann dir auch keiner so genau erklären, weil der Witz ist ja, wenn du nach Süden guckst,
dann guckst du quasi, wenn du auf der richtigen, sag mal so, wenn du auf der Südhalbkugel bist
und Richtung Süden zum Südpol guckst, dann gucken alle in die gleiche Richtung, was
bei einer flachen Erde nicht so wäre, dann würden alle in unterschiedliche Richtungen
gucken, weil ja der Südpol quasi ein großer Eiskreis noch mal außen drum herum ist, keine
Ahnung, es ergibt an sehr vielen Stellen, auf sehr vielen Ebenen keinen Sinn, deswegen
kann ich auch nicht nachvollziehen, wie man das 2022 ernsthaft glauben kann, gut, ich
meine, ich kann keinem, ich will keinem seinen Glauben verbieten, und ich kann keinen bekehren,
der da irgendwie fest davon überzeugt ist, soll mir alles recht sein, aber dann müssen
sie mit auch klarkommen, wenn ich mich drüber lustig mache, also ja, es gibt so viele Sachen,
es gibt auch, und es ist umgedreht, es gibt so viele Sachen, die man relativ einfach machen
kann, um, ja, schon, sagen wir so, zumindest große Zweifel daran aufzuwerfen, dass die
Erde flach ist, zum Beispiel eines der Sachen, die heute jeder machen kann, das ist mal ganz
davon abgesehen, dass du mit jeder 0x15 Kamera auch schon heutzutage teilweise sogar die Saturnringe
auflösen kannst, ja, also passendes Objektiv und eine ordentliche Kamera, du kannst Saturnringe
erkennen, wenn die Nacht klar ist, also das ist schon hart, was wir da in geiler Technik
mittlerweile für jeden erschwinglich haben, naja, zumindest so eine Sache, die ich gut
finde, die auch theoretisch jeder machen kann, ist, wir gehen mal von den oldschool Sachen
weg, also so nach dem Motto, vom Strand ein Schiff beobachten, wie es hinter dem Horizont
verwendet, das ist ja, das kennt man ja schon seit hunderte von Jahren, was ich jetzt in
der modernen, modernen Test ganz gut finde, ist, geht an den Strand mit einer Drohne und
einer Kamera dran, wartet bis die Sonne untergeht, also bis die Sonne quasi gerade verschwunden
ist, hinter dem Horizont, was ich witzig finde, dass die auch das Wort Horizont verwenden,
und dann fliegt ihr mit der Drohne hoch und auf einmal seht ihr die Sonne wieder, ja,
wie kann denn das sein, richtig, so ist es, das ist genau das, was ich meine, es gibt
viele Sachen, wo du, manches hast du erstmal nur theoretisch und es dauert ewig, bis es
bestätigt wird, manche Sachen werden auch nie, wie soll man sagen, bewiesen in dem
Moment, aber wichtig ist ja, was du dann damit anfangen kannst, und das weißt du oftmals
ja noch gar nicht, zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo irgendeiner mal einen schlauen Einfall hat, keine Ahnung,
dass wir dann vielleicht in 200 Jahren wegen irgendeinem schlauen Einfall, den jetzt einer
hatten, irgendwie was super geiles, Neues haben, ja, und dass gerade die Leute, die dann
an ihrem Smartphone sitzen, und mit dem Navi, ich meine, das ist die krasseste Kombination,
überlegt euch doch mal, es sitzt jemand im Auto, vielleicht sogar noch in einem Elektroauto,
stelle ich es mal vor, es sitzt jemand in einem Elektroauto mit einem Smartphone, mit
einem Navigationsgerät, mit GPS, Internet, Smartphone, Elektroauto, und gleich haben,
so, und hat überhaupt keine Zweifel daran, dass er an seinem Ziel ankommt, und auf der
anderen Seite geht er dann auf YouTube und sagt, flache Erde beste, ich hab keinen Platz
in Schimmer, was mit den Leuten los ist, Alter, ja, es gibt so viel Schwachsinn, Alter, was
ich auch mal interessant finden würde, eine Debatte, hohlerde vs. flache Erde, weil beides
geht ja schlecht, also die Erde kann ja nicht flach sein und hohl, weil wenn die flach
ist, ist kein Platz in der, wobei, ganz ehrlich, sicher ist bei den Leuten nix, ja, das ist
genauso wie Heilsteine, die machen ja auch alles wieder gesund, ja. Kommt darauf an,
wie flach, ja, vielleicht kugelflach, also vielleicht ist es ja auch eher so ne Beule,
dass es irgendwo groß genug ist, aber da rennst flach, so, das ist so bescheuert, mir bis
jetzt noch nicht bekannt, aber es würde mich jetzt nicht wundern, wenn da schon Leute
irgendwelche Zusammenhänge hergestellt hätten, ich mein, näher dran als er kannst du an einem
Echsenmensch ja nicht sein, also, ganz ehrlich, bevor ich an flache Erde glaube, dann glaube
ich nie mehr daran, dass Zuckerberg ein Echsenmensch ist. Genau, das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte,
wichtig ist, dass du das Modell, was du hast, dass du damit gewisse Sachen quasi erklären
kannst, beziehungsweise, wenn du sie erklären kannst, dann auch sagen, was eintreten wird,
wenn du dann zum Beispiel schaffst, eine Mondfinsternis voraus zu sagen und auch genau zu welchen Uhrzeiten,
zu welchen Teilen auf der Welt was wie wo sichtbar ist, goodluck, have fun mit irgendeiner Flat
Earth Geschichte. Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding, je nachdem, also, die Griechen, die hatten
ja beispielsweise, also, es gab schon ein paar super Pfeifertgriechen, die haben auch
schon gesagt, die Erde ist quasi rund, ja, die Erde, es haben tatsächlich erstaunlich
viele damals zur Zeit von Griechen und Römern gedacht, die Erde ist rund, weil, allerdings
aus komplett falschen Gründen, die haben damals gesagt, ja gut, wir sind die Geilsten
und wir sind in der Mitte, weil wir die Geilsten sind und damit wir in der Mitte sein können,
muss das ja quasi rund sein, dass alles zu uns hin fließt, so, das haben die sich damals
gedacht und haben quasi deswegen gesagt, die Erde ist rund, ich mein, es mag zwar richtig
sein, aber wie man dahingelangt, es war nicht richtig. Es ist alles fake, was widerspricht,
ja, internationale Raumstationaufnahmen, Mondlandung, Asteroidenfotos, Beobachtung,
ist alles fake, muss fake sein, weil man kann es ja nicht erklären, was auch fake ist,
sind Aufnahmen vom Südpol, wo die Leute Sonnenbewegungen am Südpol aufnehmen, was auch fake, man kann
ja angeblich noch nicht mal zum Südpol, man kann ja angeblich noch nicht mal bis zum
Südpol fahren, weil die Regierung das verbietet, Problem ist halt, man kann legit Jobs annehmen
am Südpol, also man kann sich bewerben für Jobs am Südpol, also wenn ihr mal zum Südpol
wollte, könnt ihr euch bewerben, ist aber wahrscheinlich auch noch alles nur fake.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so, das merke ich bei allen möglichen Verschwörungs-Sachen
beziehungsweise auch bei, ja, generell sobald, sobald den Leuten was gegen den Strich geht
und da muss man halt auch mal, sag mal tatsächlich, weil die Leute immer sagen, ja der Mainstreamer,
das muss man tatsächlich vielleicht auch mal dem Mainstream dann ankreiden, dass in
letzter Zeit mit Entscheidungen sicherlich einige Leute auch Richtung Verschwörungstheorie
gedrängt wurden, so, weil sie sich überhaupt nicht mehr identifizieren konnten mit dem
Mainstream, ja, aber ich glaube auch wirklich, dass es Videos schreibst, bei vielen so ist,
dass die sich ja irgendwie überlegen vorkommen, so nach dem Motto, ich weiß Bescheid, ihr
wisst nicht Bescheid und dementsprechend bin ich quasi Fiveheadiger als ihr, weil ich
hab's durchschaut und ihr seid quasi Mainstream-Schlafschafe, die quasi nur diesem Zeug nachrennen können
und ihr könnt nicht selbst denken und ich kann angeblich selbst denken, also vermute
ich, dass bei solchen Leuten im Gehirn vorgeht, ja und er kann das und deswegen fühlt er
sich dann irgendwie überlegen, ja, die Sache ist halt die, du kannst da solche Leute nicht
ausreden, weil, und das ist das, was ich meine damit, da muss ich der Mainstream teilweise
an die eigene Nase fassen, weil, weil überreden bzw. drängen, ihre Meinung zu ändern, das
funktioniert nicht, also du kannst vielleicht mit sehr viel Zeit und genug Zeit, dass sich
das setzt, vielleicht Leute von gewissen Zusammenhängen überzeugen, wenn sie das quasi, wenn das in
ihrem eigenen Hirn entsteht, dass das so sein muss, wenn du die Leute versuchst quasi zu
drängen, zu überreden, sie auszugrenzen und zu sagen, hier, wenn du das jetzt nicht glaubst
und wenn du das jetzt nicht machst, dann hast du Nachteile und so, das wird kein überzeugen
und das haben wir glaube ich auch die letzten Jahre über gesehen, dass deswegen durch solche
Versuche einige Leute tatsächlich zu, in Richtung, man sagt so Verschwörungstheorien
getrieben wurden dadurch, dass sie sich eben mit dem, ja, mit der Mainstream Meinung nicht
mehr identifizieren konnten und anstatt, dass man versucht hat mit den Leuten zu reden,
ich sage nicht, dass man mit jedem reden kann, aber man kann auch nicht zu jedem sagen, Alter,
du Kack, Verschwörungstheoretiker, pauschal, dass dann welche gesagt haben, ok, ja dann,
dann fühle ich mich hier überhaupt nicht mehr zugehörig und guck mir lieber Obamas
Exenmensch Bodyguard an. Also es hat sich die letzten Jahre eher noch mehr verhärtet
und das Problem dabei ist, dass beide Seiten extrem festgefahren sind, also es wird ja
kaum noch irgendwie auf sachlicher Ebene da was ausgetauscht, was schwierig ist mittlerweile
auch, sondern es ist quasi eher schon auf der Ebene so nach dem Motto, hier, wer das
nicht weiß ist dumm, oder wer das nicht weiß, ja, was weiß ich, das leide ich das Thema,
aber da muss sich der Mainstream denke ich schon an die eigene Nase greifen, gerade während
Corona ist da viel passiert auch an Informationen, wo sich rausgestellt hat, dass sie nicht gestimmt
haben, aus welchem Grund auch immer, vielleicht wusste man das vorher nicht besser, kann
ja alles sein, wo sich rausgestellt hat, das hat nicht gestimmt oder wo sich rausgestellt
hat, man hat absichtlich Mist erzählt und das hat man niemals danach wieder großartig
thematisiert und das war meiner Ansicht nach ein Fehler, weil du gerade dann Leute darin
schon bestärkt hast, ja und ich war auch kein Fan, also ihr wisst, ich habe mich selbst
impfen lassen, aber ich war nie Fan von der Idee, dass man Leute zwingen soll sich impfen
zu lassen und umso mehr du die Leute quasi da versucht hast von allen Seiten zu bereden,
umso verhärteter ist das im Prinzip alles geworden, auf der anderen Seite bin ich aber
auch der Meinung, wenn einer aktiv sich dagegen entscheidet und dann jeden Tag in Bus und
Bahn sitzt und sich ansteckt und Probleme bekommt, dann ist er selbst dran schuld, im
Prinzip ist jeder selbst dran schuld, naja und das ist auch wichtig, das finde ich ist
ein wichtiger Punkt, am Ende sollte man auch selbst dran schuld sein, es sollten nicht
andere irgendwie eingezwungen haben dazu, sondern ich finde es immer gut, wenn man selbst
die Möglichkeit hat was zu entscheiden und dann im Endeffekt aber auch sich eingestehen
muss, wenn man Mist entschieden hat, ja ich kann mich auch entscheiden ohne Gurt Auto
zu fahren, das ist keine gute Idee und dann kommen wir schon in Bereichen, wo man tatsächlich
sagen kann, ok sollte man das nicht vielleicht doch besser vorschreiben, ist halt nur die
Frage, wo die Linie verläuft, weil du kannst nicht alles vorschreiben, dann kann keiner
mehr ohne quasi dreifachen Antrag und Durchschlag auf die Straße gehen, du kannst aber auch
nicht alles offen lassen, weil dann ist absolut Chaos angesagt, wenn jeder komplett machen
könnte was er will, es ist halt nur die Frage, wo die Linie am Ende verläuft, also bis zu
welchem Punkt sagst du es ok, wo sagst du es nicht mehr ok und ich finde da hat sich
in den letzten Jahren die Linie ein bisschen zu sehr verschoben zu wir wollen erstmal
Sachen verbieten bzw. reglementieren, bürokratisieren wie auch immer, weil wir da keine bessere
Antwort dafür haben und das finde ich keine sonderlich schöne Entwicklung und das hat
mit Sicherheit Leute auch in Richtung Verschwörungstheorien getrieben, weil sie sich dort nicht mehr zugehörig
gefühlt haben, also beim Mainstream.
Ja, es ist echt so, wir hatten tausende Jahre lang richtig gefeifert Leute, wait a minute,
aber was ist da ein G, also irgendwo her muss man mal drauf gekommen sein, ja also das Gegenargument
von Flat Earthen ist zum Beispiel, dass es Gravitation nicht gibt, sondern das an der
Dichte hängt, der ja keine Ahnung, der Umgebungsluft, ich hab keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt, ne also
die Sache ist halt die, dass du damit eben nicht erklären kannst, warum wenn ich vom
Messeturm springe, ich unten aufklatsche und ziemlich auseinander platze und nicht nach
oben fliege, man weiß es nicht, ich kenne nur die Exen Menschen, das habe ich nicht
gesehen oder kommt auf den Kontext an, was er gesagt hat.
Ja es gibt, wo wir gerade dabei sind, es gibt doch auch genauso Leute, die panische Angst
vor, keine Ahnung, früher waren es Leute, die haben Angst vor Mikrowellen, das muss
ich euch an der Stelle mal erzählen, meine Mutter, die dachte früher, man darf nicht
vor der Mikrowelle stehen, weil und ich hab keine Ahnung, wie sie darauf kommt, aber
wenn man sich nie damit beschäftigt hat, kann ich das verstehen, weil da kommt Strahlung
raus und bei der war Strahlung gleich radioaktiv und die hat dann quasi, weil sie gehört hat,
aus der Mikrowelle kommt Strahlung raus, was ja, ich mein, mach mal das Fenster auf, da
kommt auch Strahlung rein, ganz schön viel sogar tagsüber, so und, dass das nix mit
radioaktiver Strahlung zu tun hat, war ja halt so nicht klar, so und deswegen hat sie früher
zu mir immer gesagt, ich soll nicht in die Nähe von der Mikrowelle gehen und mich schon
gar nicht im laufenden Betrieb vor die Mikrowelle stellen, weil Strahlung und Strahlung radioaktiv
und so und ich dachte, wie ich klein war, wirklich ein Atomkraftwerk und meine Mikrowelle ist
ähnlich gefährlich, kein Witz, hab ich früher wirklich gedacht, bis ich dann irgendwann
mal dahinter gekommen bin, dass das komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe sitzt, man glaubt
das, man glaubt das ja, naja, vor einer kaputten Mikrowelle stehen ist insofern blöd, da wird
halt ziemlich warm, weil du hast dann auch relativ viel Wasser so in dir drin, also du
wirst warm, deswegen sagen die ja auch, dass man keine Haustiere in die Mikrowelle stellen
sollte. Ja, nice, also ich kann dir empfehlen, also wie gesagt, diese Ruckus Access Points,
die gibt es relativ günstig, die gebrauchten Versionen, die sind featuretechnisch wirklich
nice. Ja, es hat 1,5 Jahre offen, aber das letzte
Kommet ist, dass sich die Core-Maintainer jetzt irgendwie drum kümmern, also vielleicht
schaffen sie es ja irgendwann mal ein bisschen. Es sind ganz schön viele Femto-Sekunden,
gibt auch Femto-Ampere natürlich, Femto ist ja quasi dann nur eine Größenordnung, so
im Endeffekt. Ja, das wird halt wieder nix. Du hattest damals
einem Streamer ein Zertifikate gebaut. Nix, ich hab den Pull-Request nicht aufgemacht.
Ich hab das nicht fertig programmiert und ich hab den Pull-Request nicht aufgemacht.
Ihr kennt mich doch, ich bin bei sowas immer nicht sonderlich ausdauernd, weil ich hab
ja nicht das Stehvermögen dazu, immer die Sachen auch mal fertig zu machen.
Ich wette, du hast dich nur verschrieben, dass der automatische Filter das nicht zensiert
darf. Nope, kenn ich nicht. Es gibt jetzt eine League of Legends Pro-Gamer-Serie, hab ich
heute die Werbung auf Twitter gesehen. Das ist aber nix für mich, weil weder LOL, noch
so quasi, wie nennt man das, so Serien, die auf Dokumentation gemacht sind, aber keine
Dokumentation sind. Das ist ein Format, das gefällt mir nicht. Arcane wollte ich auch
gucken, das soll wirklich gut sein, ja, das hab ich auch gelesen. Weißt du, warum es den
meisten Leuten schlecht geht? Also ich rede jetzt von hier. Den meisten Leuten geht schlecht,
zum größten Teil wahrscheinlich, weil es den Eltern auch schon nicht gut ging und die
meisten Leute sind reich, weil die Eltern reich waren. Es gibt allerdings genug, die
schaffen selbst. Und auf der anderen Seite, ganz im Ernst, ich glaube, viele könnten deutlich
mehr, wenn sie sich nicht darauf ausruhen würden, zu sagen, ja, das sollen mal alles
andere für mich machen, beziehungsweise es sollen mal quasi, so nach dem Motto, die ganze
Welt dafür sorgen, dass es mir gut geht. Ich glaube, wenn mal mehr Leute sich an die
eigene Nase fassen würden, warum es ihnen schlecht geht, ich sag nicht, dass man alles
irgendwie immer, immer, wie soll ich sagen, umschiffen kann, aber wenn die meisten Leute
mal wirklich realistisch sich Gedanken machen würden um ihre eigene Situation und vielleicht
auch mal in Kauf nehmen würden, dass sie sich eingestehen müssen oder dass sie sich eingestehen
würden, dass Sachen, die sie machen, nicht so schlau sind oder nicht so gut sind für
das, was sie eigentlich am Ende passieren soll, hätte ihnen schon mal vieles geholfen,
zum Beispiel, wenn ich Probleme habe, meine Miete zu bezahlen oder wenn ich Probleme habe,
über die Runden zu kommen, Minus am Ende des Kontos, aber ich jeden Monat mein Auto
tune und ich weiß, dass es so Leute gibt, da ist jetzt nur ein Ding dafür, da muss ich
mich nicht wundern und man muss nicht von Plus Minus Null auf Plus Minus Null, also
man muss nicht zwangsläufig alles, was man bekommt, diesen Monat irgendwie ausgeben und
sich dann ärgern, wenn irgendwas kaputt geht, dass man jetzt kein Geld hat, natürlich ist
das alles nicht easy und sich gerade auch mal einzugestehen, dass man vielleicht blödsinnige
Sachen in der Vergangenheit gemacht hat, ist schwierig, alternativ alles in Krypto und
Hodl, genau, aber ich denke, die meisten Leute könnten durchaus was dran ändern, dass es
ihnen scheiße geht, es gibt ja zig tausend Gründe, warum es einem scheiße gehen kann,
ich habe jetzt mal einen rausgesucht, ich glaube, die meisten Leute könnten tatsächlich schon
was ändern, wenn sie sich nicht darauf ausruhen würden und sagen, ja, die restliche Welt
soll mal dafür sorgen, dass es mir besser geht, das habe ich ganz krass gesehen, auf
dem Kurs, den ich beim Arbeitsamt mal machen musste, ich habe da auch so ein Video aufgenommen,
wer das im Detail sehen will, möchte ich nie wieder machen, Arbeitsamt, das war ein Kurs,
nur ganz kurz, weil ihr wahrscheinlich das Video schon gesehen habt, das war ein Kurs,
da waren so viele Leute in meinem Alter drin, oder sogar jüngere, jüngere, ich war damals
ja auch schon, was war ich denn da, als ich da hin musste, 19, nee, nee, nee, war sogar
schon ein bisschen älter, 21 oder so, da waren ganz viele 16-, 17-, 18-Jährige dabei und
die waren fester Überzeugung, also viele von denen, die in diesem Kurs waren, die waren
fester Überzeugung, dass die gesamte Welt dafür zu sorgen hat, dass es ihnen besser
geht und nicht sie selber, ja, jeder zweite Satz war so nach dem Motto, ah, dann muss
dann das Arbeitsamt, ah, dann muss dann die Regierung, ah, dann muss dann was auch immer,
wer irgendwas musste, plus sie mussten gar nichts, ehrlich gesagt, das einzige, was sie
gemusst haben, anscheinend war Kinderkriegen, weil Kinder hatten sie irgendwie alle schon
mit teilweise 18, wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, was ist mit euch verkehrt, ich meine,
manch passiert es halt so, aber das hatte schon echt System dort bei diesem Kurs und wenn
sie nicht irgendwie schon ein, zwei Kinder hatten, da waren sie auch gerade schwanger
und die waren deutlich jünger als ich damals alle auf dem Kurs und da war halt so was wie,
das war wirklich eines der einschneidesten Dinger, die jemals jemand zu mir gesagt hat
und das war unbeabsichtigt, das ist das, was ich gesagt habe, die meisten Leute sind
arm, weil es den Eltern schon nicht viel besser gehen, umgedreht, die meisten Leute
sind reich, weil die Eltern reich sind, aber es gibt ja auch noch was dazwischen und das
in diesem Arbeitsamtkurs, das heißt auch nicht, dass man nichts dagegen machen kann,
man darf es halt auch nicht über seine Verhältnisse dann drehen, aber diese Leute in dem Arbeitsamtkurs
waren wirklich echt so super krasses Beispiel, da war eine dabei, die hat versucht, ich weiß
gar nicht mehr was, die wollte irgendwas vom Arbeitsamt, wahrscheinlich irgendwas bezahlt
haben oder so und die hat sich beschwert, dass das Arbeitsamt ihr nie antwortet beziehungsweise
sie die Antworten nicht versteht, beziehungsweise die Antworten noch was ganz was anderes sagen
als das, was sie geschrieben hat und da habe ich sie gefragt, ob sie mir das mal zeigen
kann, was sie da so hinschreibt, was sie da so hingeschrieben hat, so Leute, diesen Brief,
ich weiß warum die ihr nichts geantwortet haben, beziehungsweise so komische Antworten
geschrieben haben, das war nicht lesbar und das war schon mit dem Computer getippt, die
Sätze waren nicht lesbar, das war eine gefühlt random Meister Zusammenreiung an Wörter, die
eventuell entfernt an deutsche Wörter erinnern, das konntest du nicht lesen, das war unmöglich,
so und dann habe ich sie gefragt, hast du das geschrieben, und dann meinte sie, nein,
das hat mein Mann geschrieben, der kann das besser und da habe ich sie gefragt, wenn das
schon besser ist, dann will ich ja nicht wissen, wie sie das schreibt, zumindest war sie der
Meinung, sie muss gar nicht besser schreiben können, weil ihr Kerl kann das ja und ich
hatte gesehen, ihr Kerl kann das auch nicht richtig, so und das sind Leute, die ich meine,
die könnten durchaus da was dran ändern, aber wenn man der Meinung ist, dass man nicht
lesen und schreiben lernen muss, weil es angeblich der Lebensgefährte kann, dann ist ja wohl
irgendwas offensichtlich verkehrt, es geht hier nicht darum, dass man lernt Geige zu
spielen oder Speedcubing oder wie heißt das andere Zeug, dieses Becher stacken oder so,
also es geht hier nicht um irgendwelche nice to have skills, die nicht weiter wild ist,
weil man die nicht kann, sondern um lesen und schreiben und wenn man denkt, das muss
man nicht machen, dann hat man nicht das gemacht, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe, sich nämlich
mein Ruhe Gedanken zu gemacht, warum man in dieser Situation ist, wo man gerade ist,
ich weiß, warum ich damals hin musste zu diesem Kurs, das kann ich euch sagen und ich wollte
nicht, dass die Welt das für mich ändert oder so, ich kann euch sagen, warum ich damals
zu diesem Kurs bin, ich bin damals zu diesem Kurs und ich musste damals zu diesem Amtsamtkurs,
weil ich 24-7 MMO gegrindet habe und ich nichts anderes gemacht habe und ich auch nichts anderes
machen wollte und ich mich um alles gedrückt habe, was irgendwie notwendig gewesen wäre
zu machen, also bin ich dann im Endeffekt da gelandet, heute mache ich so, ich mache
das Mindeste, was nötig ist, dass so mein Leben laufen kann und die restliche Zeit mache
ich dann halt Kreiselgrind, Kreiselgrind kann alles sein, vom Streamen bis zum Programmieren
bis zu irgendwas, worauf ich Bock habe, damals habe ich 24-7 Kreiselgrind gemacht, heute
mache ich halt nur, wie gesagt, Kreiselgrind ist jetzt sinnbildlich für Sachen, die man
gerne macht, heute mache ich halt nur noch die Hälfte der Zeit sowas, okay und manche
Leute haben noch nicht mal dafür Zeit, die können, wenn es hoch kommt, 2-3 Stunden die
Woche machen, worauf sie Bock haben, aber ich meine, irgendwann muss es einem ja auch
mal dämmern, irgendwann muss es einem doch auch mal dämmern, dass man vielleicht selbst
zumindest ein bisschen Einfluss auf das hat, was mit einem passiert, aber gut, man kann
auch alternativ in die passende Telegram Gruppe und da kriegt man schon erzählt, warum
die Welt so kacke ist und man kann ja selbst gar nichts dafür, das fällt für mich in
die gleiche Kategorie, wie Leute, die der Meinung sind, es ist eigentlich egal, was
man macht, weil es ist eh alles vorherbestimmt und Gott hat sich das eh schon überlegt für
einen und das heißt, man muss eigentlich gar nichts machen, weil man kann eh nichts
ändern, das ist ein bisschen zu einfach aus meiner Sicht, es ist natürlich eine super
Ausrede für, dass man eigentlich machen kann, was man will, weil man hat eh keine freie
Auswahl, was zu tun, was man will, eh alles schon, alles vom Vorfeld, calculated, ja,
aber das, da macht man sich doch ein bisschen einfach.
Ja, ich finde, man muss das gar nicht so, wie gesagt, ich hab mich auch empfohlen lassen,
aber ich finde, man muss das gar nicht, das ist unter anderem, ich weiß, du meinst das
nicht so, aber das ist halt unter anderem eine der Sachen, wo man halt die Leute, eh,
wo man die Leute halt nicht mit überzeugt, wenn man sie quasi so hinstellt, als wären
sie blöd, dass sie sich nicht impfen lassen und ich weiß, viele Leute von euch sagen
jetzt instinktiv, ja, die sind ja auch blöd, aber ich bin der Meinung, das muss jeder selbst
wissen und wenn jemand für sich selbst entscheidet, er hat da keinen Bock drauf, er will keine
Nadel in den Arm kriegen oder in den Poppes oder in den Beinen oder in die Wade, keine
Ahnung, wo er sich so alles impfen lässt, ehm, dann ist das sein gutes Recht, dann sollte
man das entscheiden können, das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte, das ist die Frage, wo
du die Linie ziehst zwischen Vorschreiben und, also zwischen dem Endeffekt zwischen
Vorschreiben und Freiheit und ja, wie strikt du da die Linie ziehst, ich bin der Meinung,
wenn es ums Thema Impfen geht, sollte das jeder selbst entscheiden und es hat sich jetzt ja
durchaus auch schon raus, ehm, gestellt, dass es negative Auswirkungen gab, zwar sehr
wenig, aber dass es negative Auswirkungen gab und dass dort dann das Gegenteil passiert
ist, hab ich beispielsweise, glaub, vom MDR, ja, mit irgendwas muss ich mit meinen Rundfunkgebühren
ja mal was Sinnvolles gucken, letzten Beitrag gesehen, glaub, vom MDR war's, von einem,
von zwei, von einer, die im Rollstuhl sitzt und man vermutet, das hat was mit der Impfung
zu tun und von einem, der, glaube ich, richtig Hardcore-Herz-Kreislauf-Belastungsprobleme
kaum noch die Treppe laufen konnte, auch relativ nah nach der Prüfung und die wollten
das beide melden beim, frag mich nicht, für welches Institut dafür, das ist nicht das
Robert-Koch-Institut, ich glaub, irgendein anderes Institut muss, kann man, kann man das
ja melden, wenn man denkt, man hat Impfschäden und, ehm, die haben beide berichtet so nach
dem Motto, es wollte niemand hören, obwohl aus ihrer Sicht zeitlich ganz klar, ehm,
dass Zusammenhänge gegeben kann, es wollte niemand hören, Paul-Ehrlich-Institut, du
hast recht, genau, das, das meint, es wollte niemand hören und es wollte sie keiner untersuchen
im Zusammenhang, deswegen, das ist halt auch nicht gut, ja, das, so sollte das auch nicht
sein, ich finde, du solltest von beiden Seiten, sollte das realistisch, realistisch betrachtet
werden, man sollte klar sehen, okay, die Chancen, dass mir was passiert, sind sehr gering, aber
die andere Seite sollte auch sagen, okay, wir sind interessiert dran und wir müssen
die Sachen, die gemeldet werden, auch gewissenhaft verfolgen und nichts zu sagen, am Ende, ja,
hauptsache die Statistik sieht schön aus.
Das ist auch im Endeffekt das, was auch Vertrauen in solche Abläufe schafft und in Zahlen und
Ergebnissen schafft und da haben wir an vielen Stellen die letzten paar Jahre tatsächlich
verkackt, das muss man auch mal sehen, ich, egal, ich nehme nicht zu viel von das Thema,
ich habe eigentlich überhaupt kein Bock mehr drauf.
So, ich glaube, ich muss jetzt erst mal in den Chat, es sind 22.20 Leute, ich habe Bett
Get vergessen, ich war viel zu sehr am erzählen, Bett Get Time, ich habe nichts gemacht, wir
haben ein bisschen Chat gelesen, ich habe geschwätzt, wir haben uns das Bild aus dem Zentrum der
Milchstraße angeguckt, der Labelchamp, den muss ich auch noch weitermachen, welche Software
nutzt du eigentlich, um die Soundclips einzuspielen, das ist was selbst gebasteltes, das sieht
so aus, das ist ein Webinterface, das habe ich auf dem zweiten Monitor auf und klick
dann da drauf und dann habe ich dann Sound und Bilder oder zum Beispiel so was hier Bilder
und Sound, wo wir es gerade von Verschwörungstheorien hatten, was macht er eigentlich gerade, lange,
lange nicht gehört, ich habe gehört Xavier Naidoo ist bekehrt wieder, ist jetzt wieder
auf dem rechten Pfad zurück angeblich, aber wahrscheinlich ist ihm einfach nur das Geld
ausgegangen, keine Ahnung, hast du deine Meinung zu den neuen Prüfungen nach der neuen Ausbildungsordnung
in der IT?
Ne, ich kenne die neuen Prüfungen nicht, keine Ahnung, ich darf die Prüfungen auch
nicht zeigen im Stream, weil die sind Copyright geschützt und das ist ziemlich dumm ehrlich
gesagt, das ist richtig beschissen, dass man diese Prüfungen nicht zeigen darf, das wäre
glaube ich echt für viele eine Hilfe, wenn wir diese Prüfungen im Stream machen könnten,
erstens wegen dem Chat, der dabei ist, weil viele Leute von euch auch Plan haben und bei
denen noch nicht so lange zurück ist und ihr jetzt so was sagen könnt und weil ich jetzt
auch nicht ganz planlos bin, was das Thema angeht, ich meine ich habe den Kram selbst
gemacht, ich hatte selbst genug Azubis und ein bisschen Ahnung von der Materie habe ich
ja auch noch. Du darfst die Prüfung nicht zeigen, aber du könntest die abschreiben
in einem Text, das kommt aufs gleiche raus. Du kannst auch nicht Herr der Ringe Copypasten,
dann ist das zwar nicht abportografiert, aber es ist immer noch Herr der Ringe. Die Prüfung
war Trash, die ist jedes Jahr Trash. Da hätte ich ja überhaupt keinen Bock drauf zum Bund
zu gehen. Ja, das wie gesagt, das sehe ich auch so, das sehe ich auch so, also muss ich
ja mal angucken, also viele Leute, die reich sind, sind halt reich, weil ihre Eltern reich
waren, viele Leute, die arm sind, sind arm, weil die Eltern nichts hatten und sie halt
so aufgewachsen sind. Es gibt immer Beispiele in die andere Richtung, aber ich finde das
ist eigentlich tatsächlich eines der größten Probleme, was wir haben. Wie sagt man da so
plakativ, also die Fähre zwischen Arm und Reich. Jetzt muss ich mal was sagen, jetzt
wäre wahrscheinlich Twitter wahnsinnig getriggert, wenn ich das da öffentlich sage, aber ich
glaube, der Unterschied, ob du männlich oder weiblich bist, hat was deine Chancen angeht
und was du später mal werden kannst, hat viel viel weniger damit zu tun, als ob du
in einem reichen oder in einem armen Elternhaus aufgewachsen bist. Ich glaube, Twitter wäre
wahnsinnig getriggert, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, wenn man da mal jetzt ein bisschen
nachforschen würde, würde man auch Belege dafür finden. So ist es nur eine Aussage
von mir, ohne dass ich euch jetzt irgendwelche Fakten untermauern kann, aber es klingt mir
einfach sehr naheliegend. Ich finde, das ist ein leidiges Thema, wo viel zu viel aktuell
jeder was zu sagen hat. Das ist im Prinzip genauso wie Gendersternchen oder Nicht-Gendersternchen,
jeder hat da eine Meinung zu, weil es ein einfaches, zu erfassendes und griffiges Thema
ist. Ich habe da natürlich auch eine Meinung zu, aber unabhängig davon, ob man dafür oder
dagegen ist, eigentlich ändert es an der Welt, oder wie soll ich sagen, eigentlich
ändert es erstaunlich wenig, ob man das jetzt macht oder nicht macht. Letztendlich ist es
ziemlich wurscht und es ist halt ein beliebtes Thema, sich darüber aufzuregen, gerade auf
Twitter und das ist genauso wie diese Geschichte mit, was weiß ich, haben es Frauen zu schwer,
verdienen Frauen zu wenig, das ist auch so was, ja es gibt sicherlich Bereiche, da
würde ich das auch so sehen, da haben wir noch was zu tun, aber wenn man sich überlegt
und das muss man echt auch mal zu schätzen wissen, wie viel sich die letzten 40, 50 Jahre
Reichheit schon getan hat, generell was Gleichberechtigung angeht und auch wenn man guckt, was sich
im Thema Rassismus getan hat, die Welt ist auch heute viel, viel besser in diesen Belangen,
als sie noch vor 50 Jahren war, aber wenn man sich das Getriggere und das Geschreie
auf Twitter anhört, ich sag nicht, dass alles gut ist, ich sag nicht, dass wir nicht an
manchen Stellen noch was machen können, aber wenn man sich das Getriggere und das Geschreie
auf Twitter anhört, könnte man davon ausgehen, wenn man nichts anderes kennt, dass es heute
so schlimm ist, wie es noch nie gewesen ist, also dass es heute schlimmer ist denn je und
das ist es einfach nicht, muss ich einfach mal historisch angucken, was da abgegangen
ist, heute ist eigentlich ziemlich gut, heute hast du so viele persönliche Entfaltungsmöglichkeiten,
also ich rede jetzt von Deutschland, ich will hier im Nahen Osten gucken oder so, in Deutschland,
du hast heute hier so viele Möglichkeiten dich frei zu entfalten, wie noch nie vorher und
ein ganz offensichtliches Beispiel, was die letzten Jahre über passiert ist, heute kannst
du sagen, ich bin Gamer, da sagen die Leute cool, was spielst du denn so, ja ich spiele
gerne, mein Eisverkäufer, mit dem hab ich mich letztens über Counter Strike unterhalten
und dann hat er mir erzählt, er hat 8000 Euro in irgendeinem komischen Mobile Game ausgegeben,
aber das ist normal, heute kannst du nicht sagen, ich bin Gamer, vor, ohne Scheiß, als
ich in die Schule gegangen bin, da war Gamer sein nicht gerade cool, das hat sich einfach
mal komplett gedreht, ja, heute haben die krassen Fortnite Pros, machen Millionen und
haben die hottesten Girlfriends und als ich in die Schule gegangen bin, wenn du da Computersachen
gespielt hast auf der Konsole, haben sie Schäbange geguckt, also gerade sowas in der persönlichen
Entfaltung, das Musterbeispiel schlechthin dafür, hat sich so viel getan und man muss
sich auch immer fragen, was man will, das ist das letzte, was ich dazu sage, weil ansonsten
wäre ich gar nicht fertig und ich muss den Chat noch durchgehen, man muss sich eine Sache
fragen und das kommt, finde ich, ein bisschen kurz, auch bei den getriggerten Leuten auf
Twitter, möchte man, jetzt haltet euch fest, wahrscheinlich muss ich ein bisschen genauer
erklären, möchte man so statistische Gleichverteilung, also sprich überall 50% Frauen und 50% Männer
oder möchte man Chancengleichheit haben und du willst ziemlich sicher Chancengleichheit
haben, du willst keine 50-50 überall haben, weil wenn du 50-50 überall anstrebst, das
bedeutet, du musst Leute zwingen, Dinge zu machen, auf die sie keinen Bock haben, das
ist das genaue Gegenteil von freier persönlicher Entfaltung und das willst du nicht, was du
willst, ist die gleichen Chancen zu haben und da sind, um jetzt mal den Bogen zu spannen,
zurück zu dem, was Singlor geschrieben hat, ich glaube, dort ist der Unterschied, ob du
aus einem reichen oder armen Haushalt kommst, weil was Chancengleichheit angeht, das ist
der größere Faktor, als ob du männlich oder weiblich bist, so, next, nee, wie gesagt,
das geht nicht, Prüfung zeigen, egal wie, das darf ich nicht, das ist nicht erlaubt,
ja, war ich, aktuell haben wir keine Azubis mehr, also gut, beschränken genommen bin
ich kein Ausbilder, ich habe nie einen Zettel gemacht bei der IHK, aber ich habe mich um
einige Azubis gekümmert, sowohl beim Provider als auch jetzt bei der Bank, wo ich bin, also
in unserem Bereich, ich meine, Herr N-Punkt ist ja wohl das beste Beispiel für, also
einer von den Azubis, die ihr kennt, von meinen ehemaligen Azubis, der Felix beispielsweise,
mit dem ich mal auf der Games kam, aber auch mal Azubi, was ist so deine Meinung zu einer
Stelle als Systemadministrator im öffentlichen Dienst, also ich sehe, naja, gut, je nachdem,
ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen von Algorithmen verstehen, der jetzt nicht mehr Algorithmen
verstehen heißt, sondern Florian Dalvik, glaube ich, Dalvik, ja, der hat ein bisschen das
erklärt im öffentlichen Dienst und wie man da, wie das mit den Gehältern ist, also es
scheint wohl ganz entscheidend zu sein, ob du studiert hast oder nicht, weil die wohl
da etwas oldschool sind, also sprich, wenn die jemand suchen, dann hast du wohl keine
oder weniger gute Chancen, in die höheren Tarifstufen zu kommen und nicht Tarif, in
die höheren Gehaltsklassen zu kommen, wenn du nicht studiert hast und es ist auch entscheidend,
wie viel, ja, Erfahrungsjahre du quasi einsteigst, also das kann durchaus in Ordnung sein, Geld
technisch im öffentlichen Dienst zu arbeiten, gerade die übrigen Stufen waren wirklich
in Ordnung, was ich da gesehen habe, aber ich hätte da keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, ich glaube, es sollte nicht spannend, ist das in vielen Stellen nicht, wobei ich
das nicht einschätzen kann.
Ja, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich kaum was kriegen, es sei denn, die haben ihre Meinung
geändert.
Hallo Max, ich bin Python-Java-Entwickler, also neiße Kombination, kannst du hier als
Java-Entwickler nach China, die Chinesen brauchen massig Java-Entwickler, ich meine das nicht
wirklich ernst, aber es ist so, die Chinesen brauchen massig Java-Entwickler, ich weiß
auch nicht, warum die Chinesen so auf Java stehen und Python ist generell angesagt, was
Machine Learning, AI und aktuelle Sachen angeht, so, ich würde auch gerne C-Programmiersprachen
lernen, was macht er meistens in C++, gut, also, ähm, ich hab grad gedacht, du meinst
Objective-C, ne, ne, also C-Lernen ist, tja, das kommt drauf an, das kann man nicht so
einfach beantworten, wenn du hobbymäßig so ein bisschen Interesse an Micro-Controllern
hast und sowas, dann C und C++, vor allem C++, weil das ganze Arduino Zeug ist C++,
die angenehmere Sprache ist eindeutig nacktes C, weil C++ einfach mal komplett für'n
Arsch ist, außer in den Bereichen, wo man es halt, wo man es halt benutzen muss, ähm,
aber dann ist es auch nicht gut, sondern man muss es halt benutzen, ähm, ich persönlich,
wenn du einfach nur C-Style-Programmiersprachen lernen möchtest, dann kannst du C-Sharp lernen,
aber wenn du schon Java-Entwickler bist, ist der Unterschied von Java und C-Sharp jetzt
nicht wahnsinnig hoch. C-Sharp finde ich persönlich deutlich angenehmer als Java, aber ist wahrscheinlich
geschmackser, ähm, aber wenn du was Low-Level-Legeres lernen willst, dann nimm C oder Rust, wobei
Rust halt nur für 500 EQ ist. C++ ist halt das Problem, C++ ist ein Fass ohne Boden,
ein Legacy-Fass ohne Boden, und selbst wenn du quasi modernstes C++ benutzt, ist der
Komplexitätsgrad einfach so unglaublich hoch und das Ganze so inkonsistent und durchsichtig,
dass C++ eigentlich nur abfacken kann. Auf Dauer. Also Cringe, wenn C++ nicht abfackt
nach 1-2 Tagen am Stück. Und modernstes C++ kannst du in der Regel auch nicht mal machen,
weil du ja nicht für, sagen wir jetzt mal, aktuelle Desktop-Systemen immer entwickelst,
sondern gerade wenn es um irgendwelche Micro-Controller geht, sind die Tool-Chains oftmals halt nicht
gerade auf C++ 23 Beta oder so. Und selbst da ist noch nicht mal alles drin. Wie sieht
es eigentlich mit Modul-Support mittlerweile aus in Mainstream-Compilern? Haben sie das
mittlerweile alle geschafft oder nicht? Ganz davon abgesehen, Modul-Support schön und gut,
Modul-Support wird sich wahrscheinlich eh nicht so wirklich durchsetzen, weil das ein
Legacy fast ohne Boden ist und die Leute quasi Hatter-Files haben aus den letzten 100 Jahren.
Kommt auf den Bereich an, ja. C-Sharp ist auf jeden Fall richtig pock.
Aber richtig Hyper-Cringe, wenn ich 500 EQ habe. Leute, das ist auch so ein schönes
Beispiel. Async in C++. Es ist der unfertigste, undurchdachteste, halbherzigste Shit, den
ich je gesehen habe. Es ist so dumm einfach nur. Du mag C++ wahrscheinlich, weil es deine
erste Sprache ist, ansonsten. Das ist wie, dass man immer seine erste Konsole für die
Beste hält. Oder mancher ihre ersten Freunde in ihr restliches Leben lang nachweinen. Das
hat, glaube ich, wenig generellen Aussagecharakter. Ich mag C++ überhaupt nicht. Und nachdem
ich das Streamer bin, zählt das natürlich, was ich sage. Ja, ganz klar.
Ist Battlefield 2002 in C++, weil die Frostbite-Anseln... Also Frostbite ist tatsächlich eine Mischung
aus C-Sharp und C++. Beziehungsweise, man sollte eher sagen C++ und C-Sharp. Das weiß
ich, weil das irgendein damaliger Dice-Entwickler auf Twitter geschrieben hat, wo es um die
Frostbite-Tools ging. Und sie meinten, die Frostbite-Tools sind zum größten Teil in
C-Sharp programmiert mit einem Managed C++-Layer. Da wundert mich nix mehr. Wer CLI C++ macht,
da hat die Kontrolle über sein Leben verloren. Also sie haben quasi C++ und C-Sharp verheiratet
mit einem Managed.NET C++-Layer. Natürlich selbstverständlich Windows Only, weil dieser
Shit läuft nur unter Windows. Also, cringe, wer sowas macht, ich möchte nicht den Source-Code
sehen. Du musst das richtige Addon installieren. Du musst hier installieren. FFZ. Also es gibt
zwei Addons. Es gibt entweder dieses Addon oder BellaTwitchTV. Es ist eigentlich egal,
was du installierst. Beide können beide Emotes. Du musst das nur aktivieren. BellaTwitchTV
und FFZ haben beide unterschiedliche Emote-Datenbanken, aber beide Addons können die Datenbank von
jeweils anderen. Bei FFZ musst du die Settings für BellaTwitchTV aktivieren und bei BellaTwitchTV
die Settings für FFZ. Ich persönlich verwende FFZ und habe lange BellaTwitchTV verwendet,
aber verwende es auch schon ähnlich lange nicht mehr. 7TV habe ich noch nicht mich
näher mit beschäftigt. Also FFZ kann definitiv beide und ich bilde mir ein BellaTwitchTV
kann mittlerweile auch beide. Weiß ich aber nicht aus erster Hand. So Leute, schön, dass
ihr dabei gewesen seid. Heute reiner Laberstream. Schön, dass ihr da wart. Finde ich nice. Musste
auch mal sein. FFZ hat einen Kompressor. Ja, der ist wirklich nice. Leute, der Kompressor
ist wirklich gut bei FFZ. Ich zeige euch das nochmal ganz schnell. Also praktisch für
Streams die beschissene Lautstärke. Also ihr hört es, das ist dann deutlich breiter.
Bzw. halt ausgeglichener Höhen, Höhen und Tiefen und alles. Also sprich was leiser ist,
das hörst du ein bisschen lauter und so. Ist ganz praktisch gerade bei Streams und Streamern,
die ihre Audio-Settings nicht so sehr im Griff haben. Manchmal ist es auch ganz gut, wenn
man z.B. Leuten zuguckt, die was spielen und die haben den Spielsound so leise, dass
der Spielsound dadurch ein bisschen lauter wird. Je nachdem welche Frequenzbereichen
das so ist. Alles klar Leute, wir sehen uns. Machen wir Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat, da erkläre
ich es. Wir sehen uns. Alles klar Leute, bis zum nächsten Stream. Morgen gucken wir uns
die 6 Points an. Ich hoffe, dass ich dazu komme. Alles klar, bis dann. Macht's gut.